[Music]
it's been just over a year since the
Russian invasion of Ukraine Mary Jane
belieso takes us to UNLV to share the
story of a Ukrainian living in Las Vegas
and how he's making his voice heard
through music
[Music]
is a universal language one we can all
share and understand audience gets it
also not through the spoken word but
through the sounds which goes directly
to heart mind and soul krissa started at
UNLV in 2006. he has a lengthy career
spanning as a violinist playing and
conducting in top-rated Symphonies
originally from Ukraine he always thinks
of his family back home especially with
the recent passing of his uncle he used
to be compromise of national Symphony
Orchestra so
sort of musicians are everywhere in our
family it's now been a little over a
year since the Russian invasion of
Ukraine of course it's a lot more
difficult for them when you have no
electricity when you have no water the
drones flying around you and the rocket
missiles attacks despite the conflict he
couldn't pass up the opportunity to go
back to Ukraine last summer to perform
I'm amazed to the resilience of Ukraine
million people how they overcome all
these difficulties and go on with their
lives the best they can it's important
to show solidarity and support with with
what we can do our abilities to do
especially an artist and I think for us
just going there showing a support and
we're not afraid and that's that's
important
[Music]
[Applause]
to give encouragement and inspiration to
everyone my best teachers that I I still
remember that they instill into me
intellectual curiosity I'm constantly
asking why is that why is that if I do
this to my students so after they
graduate they keep progressing as
musicians and human beings
I did my job
if you would like to show your support
we'll have a list of upcoming concerts
that you can attend at UNLV on our
website for you at 8newsnow.com